Hi there. This is my message to Millennials about how to change the world and I would say how to change the world properly
[of] course the question, then is well exactly what do you mean by properly and of course that's the fundamental issue
So I'm going to walk through that little bit
So I'm gonna and I've also got an offer to make to any millennials that are willing to watch this so
This was triggered in [part] by something I read recently by Jonathan hate and Jonathan haidt is the professor of ethical leadership at the nyu
Stern school of business, and he's been a very astute
Commentator recently on some of the political battles that have been going on in the social sciences
[noting] for example that there is very little political diversity in the views of social scientists and perhaps even less on
the part of the people in the humanities
And hate recently wrote something which all all what are you linked to in the and the description of this video?
Where he claimed that universities have to decide between Social justice and truth and on the side of truth he puts
Philosopher call named John Stuart Mill an English Philosopher who said
He who knows only his side of the case knows little of that
His reasons may be good and no one may have been able to refute them
But if he is equally unable to refute the reasons on the opposite side if he does not
Does not so much as know what they are he has no ground for preferring either opinion
And then he juxtaposes
John Stuart Mill with Karl Marx who said the Philosopher's have only interpreted the world in various ways the point is to [change] it
He considers Marx the Patron Saint of Social justice
University which is oriented around changing the world in part by overthrowing power structures and privilege
It sees political diversity as an obstacle to action
male on the other hand according to hate is the Patron saint [of] what he calls truth you which sees truth as a
Process in which flawed individuals challenge each other's biased and incomplete reasoning and in the process all become smarter
Hate points out the truth university dies when it becomes intellectually uniform or politically, orthodox
So I guess this video is in part my call along with Jonathan haidt for young people to join
Truth universe versity, but there's a problem with that because the university is where the truth is being sought
That's the university, but there's a problem
and that is that young people want to change the world and it's part of what Piaget the
developmental psychologist piaget called the Messianic stage and there's some real utility in that because we're social creatures and
As we construct ourselves and formulate ourselves and bring our own character into being predicated on our on our
biological
Platform our biological being we also simultaneously have to integrate
Adjust to integrate with and negotiate with Society which sometimes needs to be changed
The structure of [Society] has to be preserved
But it has to be [updated] and proved as it moves forward and so part of the problem is how to update and improve it
without
doing [that] so rapidly that you destroy everything of any value, so
The problem I have with the marxist perspective, and I've had this problem with it for a long time
Is that I don't think [that] you should trust people whose primary goal?
when when
when they're attempting to change the world for the better is to change other people and you can tell who those people are because they're
always blaming other people and they're looking for victims they're looking for perpetrators and victims and then they're going off to stop the
perpetrators, and I think that's wrong because as
Alexander solzhenitsyn said he's a great Russian writer who helped bring down the soviet union
He said the line between good and Evil runs down every every [humans] heart
So that so the real battle as far as I'm concerned
And I think this goes along with the true tradition in [which] John stuart mill is is firmly placed in is that?
to overcome Tyranny and malevolence and
Chaos and Nihilism and the Desire to bring everything to a halt you have to repair the fissures
And-And-and the rift that's in your own soul, basically and that means that you have to confront
the the Evil that lives in your own heart
and there's a there's a statement from the new testament [that] I think is very much apropos with regards to this particular idea and
this is
This is part of the sermon on the mount which is a central text in in western in the western tradition
I would say [obviously] central to Christianity but central to everything that western civilization has built and so christ says to his followers
Why be holdest thou?
the mote that is in thy brother's eye, but considerest not the beam that is in thine own eye or
How wilt thou say to thy brother let me pull out the mote out of thine eye and behold a beam is in [thine] own
eye thou hypocrite first cast out [the] beam out of thine own eye and then
Shalt thou see clearly to cast the mote out of thy brother's eye
Well, I like that quote because it places the responsibility
For change at every level of being on the individual and obviously the individual interacts with society
But the idea here is that unless the individual straightens out his or her [own] soul
There's no possibility that the impact the individual can have on society can be anything, but [buts] a harmful in proportion to the harm
That's still in the soul. These are important [things] to know they're vitally important things to know
So okay, so but then we're faced with the conundrum that young people also want to change the world
but that's no problem because I [think] you can bring you could bring truth university together with the desire to
to make real change, but change
Change change has to start [at] the right place
so I'm going to tell you how I [think] you should change yourself so that you can change the world and
So that the world that you bring into being will be a better world and all the worst one
Remember remember you need to know about this that the world that the followers of Marx brought into being in the 20th century
Killed more than a hundred million people say in China and russia. [I] mean the soviet Union and [in] places like Cambodia and Vietnam
The world certainly changed as a consequence of Marxist doctrine
But it didn't [change] in in a good direction and of course the Marxist doctrine is
Making itself heard in a massive way across the west again now so all right
So what should you do about that? Well? Here's an idea?
The first thing you have to do is orient yourself now
You probably have all watched pinocchio and pinocchio is about how a marionette someone who's whose strings are being pulled by Forces Beyond his comprehension
[that's] the situation of the undeveloped individual
Geppetto who's a Benevolent father so a benevolent?
Symbol a symbol of benevolent culture makes a puppet his son
and then wishes on a star now a star is something that glitters up in the sky and it's and it's associated with the
Transcendent and Beyond and the divine and you know if you look up in the night, [sky]
And it's very dark [you] get a feeling of awe it's because you're confronting your soul
so to speak your individual soul is confronting the cosmos and you can feel a relationship between you and and and
and the totality so looking up into the sky is like a religious experience if it's a starry sky and
to wish upon a star is to find in a light that orient's you like the North star and
To pick a highest goal to pick the highest goal
You can conceive of and so that's what geppetto does he raises his eyes above his
his Day-To-day concerns and tries to establish a relationship with the highest of all possible values and
And and he has the most profound of wishes and the most profound of wishes is that the puppet that he's created
Could become a genuine individual genuinely fully fully developed human being and that's what you can wish for [yourself]
That's you can wish and and and and aim for that in yourself
and then
You see that's how you deal [with] the suffering that's attendant on life because life is suffering and because life is very hard and people
Get sick, and they become mentally ill and and and there's malevolence in the world
And there's tragedy and so life is very very hard
and if
you're not properly oriented with regards to life the fact that it's hard and the fact that it's full of suffering can can warp and
twist and Bend you until you become murderous and resentful and and
even go Beyond murderous and resentment to wish for for genocide and evil even to wish for [the] destruction of everything and
So you have to learn [how] to strengthen yourself as an individual [so] that you can bear?
the
Burden of being without becoming corrupt you have to decide that that is what you're aiming [for] is that you want to become [a] fully
developed human being and stop being a
Pathetic Marionette whose strings are being pulled by Horrible Forces behind the scenes
So I would say to wish on a stars to Aim at the highest good in the question, then is well
What what is the good?
well
We can answer that in two ways
We could say that the good is the opposite of evil
And I can tell you what evil is evil
is the conscious desire to produce suffering where suffering is not necessary and so if you read about
What happened in the NaZi Concentration?
camps for example or in the in the Russian concentration camps during the soviet time of the soviet union
you'll get a good flow favor for what constitutes evil and evil is the desire to exploit the vulnerability of other people to
self-consciously exploit the
Vulnerability of other people and to elevate their suffering beyond their or anyone's ability to tolerate and so the good is the opposite of that
Whatever the opposite of that is the good is harder to get a handle on but here's one hint
and I got this from reading jean Piaget partly who's a developmental pSychologist and
Piaget talked about the
Equilibrated state and in equilibrated state is like a game the children play
Where every child wants to play the game you have a little social group?
And that's the children's play group and any of us the individuals within it those are the individual children and the structure is the game
and it's a good game if everyone wants to play it and
And piaget noted that a game like that will outperform a game that people have to be terrorized to play because it doesn't entail it
doesn't require any enforcement cost and so I've sort of developed the idea of [nil] equilibrated state to think that if
If you're aiming at the good, then you want what's good for you?
And I mean good [for] you as if you were taking care of yourself, and we're good to yourself
We were treating yourself like someone you loved
That was good for you in a way that [would] also be good for your family, and then it would be good for you
And your family in a way that was also good for society and then it would be
Good for you, and your family and society in a way that would [be] good for the world
And then it would be good now
And it would be good next week and the week after and a year from now and is long into the future [as] you can
See, so the good is something that's equilibrate across multiple levels of being in multiple time frames simultaneously
And it isn't necessarily that you know what that is going to be at any given moment, but you can orient yourself
So that's the state that you [want] to exist in and I can tell you
As far [as] I [can] tell when you exist in that state
even moment by Moment
Your life is imbued with a sense of meaning and that sense of meaning can help you transcend
Suffering the Philosopher Nietzsche said he who has a why
Can Bear [anyhow] he who has a why?
Can bear [anyhow] and so Nietzsche's idea was that if there was purpose in your life of sufficient grandeur that?
not only could the suffering in life be a
but maybe it even be
appreciated like it could be that you're willing to bear the burden of being because of
the
Exciting things that you can do with being the things you can build and the things that you can bring about and that might be
The highest imaginable state of being and that's that's a form of paradise, but it's not a paradise that you attain by transforming others
It's a paradise that you attain by transforming yourself
and
That's a very difficult thing to do and it's a very frightening thing to do because it means that you're you're
Retooling your soul, and that's that's a job for a real
That's the job for a forthright and honorable person and it's an exciting enough
Task so that it will keep you occupied for the rest of your life
and then magical things will happen to you well your
While you're doing it, and the world will arrange itself around you in the most wonderful way in a musical way
So that every part of what you're experiencing plays off
against every other part in a manner that has meaning
embedded in every aspect of it and you experience that by the way you experience that when you listen to a piece of [music] that
You love music represents that and that's why people it's why music
Nourishes the soul why it's the highest form of art at least in my opinion. So you have to live your life as if
Being is a symphony, and you're playing you're playing your instrumental part
Once you are it yourself. Then you have an [obligation]
I would say an obligation to the development of your soul to speak the truth you have to be oriented properly though
Because the truth is is something that
Exists in service to an ideal an ideal of sorts then you can imagine that you could use your [language] two ways you can use
your language to manipulate the world and
To extract from it what you want, so for example
Maybe you go out on a date with someone and you decide that the end goal of the date is to
Have a sexual partner for the night and then you can craft your language to manipulate
The person into providing you with you with what you want, and that's like an instrumental use of language
But the problem with [that]. There's many problems with that
But one of them is is that what if your idea about what you should want is wrong like maybe that's not the way to
treat someone that you're on a date with out on a date with maybe maybe you're
minimizing and reducing the interactions between you
from what could be a healthy and
Elevated state of interaction and discourse to something that's that
Basically the pursuit of impulsive pleasure and not maybe that's not good for you
Next week and the week after and a month down the road maybe orienting yourself towards impulsive pleasure is a very bad idea
Remember what happens in Pinocchio pinocchio goes to pleasure island and pleasure island is a place where impulsive pleasures can be had
at a moment's notice but what pinocchio discovers along with Jiminy cricket that pleasure island is run by
masked
Totalitarians there they're all dressed in black you remember. They're there turning the children and
Adolescents who are on Pleasure Island?
They're depriving about their voice turning them into brain
Jackasses and preparing to sell them as slaves to the salt mines and so there's an implication in that story that
the pursuit of Impulse of pleasure is
One route to totalitarianism and slavery, and I believe that so perhaps
Orienting your language towards the gathering of the impulsive pleasure is a miss is a misuse of your highest gift
You're the gift of logos the gift of communication
The alternative is to orient
Yourself towards the highest good as we already described and then speak the truth which and you can you can tell when you're doing that?
because or you can tell when you're not doing that because if you're if you're not telling the truth if you're using someone else's words
You're being
Elated into sense by forces that are behind the scenes. You're not using your own words
You're the puppet of an ideology or another thinker or your own impulsive desires
And you can tell when you're speaking like that because it makes you feel weak
It makes you feel weak and ashamed and you can localize that feeling
physiologically if you listen to yourself talk
you can tell when
when you're speaking
Properly you will experience a feeling of integration and strength and when you're speaking in a deceitful or manipulative Manner
You'll feel that you're starting to come apart at the seams and what you need to do is practice
Only saying things that make you feel stronger, and that'll mean to begin with it
You'll notice that almost everything you say is a lie. It's either a lie or someone else's words
It's very hard to find your [old] words, but you don't actually exist until you have your own words
So okay, so then you you try to teach yourself how to speak your own truth
And you listen to other people while you're doing that because they can help you shape and correct your words
They'll react to them badly if you formulate your ideas
Badly and if you listen and pay attention then you can learn to formulate your words
More and more clearly and accurately and that makes you more and more powerful
It makes you it gives you more and more authority which is the which is the beneficial form of power, okay?
So you do that, and then you have to make a decision of Faith
And that's basically well that you can either either use [your] language to manipulate the world and make it do what you want
or you can use your language to try to articulate the truth as carefully as you possibly can and then
[you] can see what happens you have to let go of your desire
For the for the consequences that you want you have to assume that if you speak the [truth]
The results are the best that is possible under the circumstances
[and] so it's a it's a it's an exciting way of living in some sense some sense
It's like continually walking off a cliff because you don't know what's going to happen next [if] all you do is say what you think?
You know and maybe you're at work, and you say what you [think] and you get fired you think oh my God?
That's a terrible catastrophe, but maybe it's not because maybe if you're working somewhere, and you have to lie to maintain your job
Maybe you shouldn't be there
Maybe it's deadening your soul and damaging you in some permanent manner and making you corrupt and so
You have to orient yourself you have to speak the truth
as carefully as you can you have to listen to others so that you correct your speech and then you have to allow the
Consequences that ensue to unfold as they will that's the ultimate act of Faith
I would say and that's what you do if you belong to truth university
All right, so more practically speaking then you should educate yourself
and it's not that easy to do now because
You have to find people who can [actually] tell you mostly what to read and maybe also how to write because writing is a way
Of formulating your thoughts ever more precisely
that's why you go to university to learn how to write if you learn if you know how to write you can think if
You can think and speak and communicate in writing? You're you're unbelievably?
powerful in the Authority Manner because
arguments move the world Forward and if your arguments are tight and [well-constructed] and
Lucid and well edited and carefully thought through and you have five rationales for everything that you're doing
Which is what happens if you learn to write properly, then you're like a force of nature man
No one can take you down
And that's one of the things that people aren't taught about why you go get educated especially in the humanities
humanities education if it's real
organizes your pSyChe
grounds you puts you on a
Rock and makes you a force to contend with [but] you have to read the right people and so and those are the great
They're the great people of the past in [my] list
they're the great men of the past and that's just how it is and
So here's who I would recommend I put reading lists up at Jordan B
Peterson Com there's two of them and the people that I recommend
Primarily are their books written by the followed list of people Fyodor [dostoyevsky]
Leo Tolstoy, who I think perhaps the greatest novelists the world has ever seen
Alexander solzhenitsyn another great russian novelist. I don't know what it is about the russians, but man they produce they produce writers that are
incomparable Alexander solzhenitsyn wrote a book called [the] gulag archipelago
where he analyzed the soviet prison Camp system that arose after the leninist revolution in the second decade of the 20th century and
details [an] absolutely precisely how the
[tenets] of Marxism the Marxist tenants that are supposed to free everyone and change the world produce legislation
[that] was that was absolutely murderous in its consequences and solzhenitsyn
Painstakingly traces the logical Pathway from the original Marxist principles to the legislation to the to the genocides
because you'll hear people who are basically marxist to say things like well true Marxism never existed and
Solzhenitsyn took that bad argument apart in the in the [mid-70s] and and the gulag archipelago was an intellectual bomb it it
it
demolished any
Credibility that Marxism had to intellectual respectability you have to read the book
The book is about the central issue in our culture at the moment if you don't read it. You're not informed
You can't participate in the debate except as a puppet and so I wouldn't recommend
Participating in this debate as a puppet because you don't know who's behind the scenes pulling the strings if you remember the pinocchio story
The forces that we're pulling the strings were not
They were not forces that were acting in Pinocchio's
best interest that's for sure George orwell English essayist incomparable commentator on
Socialist totalitarianism even though he was a left winger and a Brilliant one aldous Huxley wrote brave New world
Had some very brilliant things to say about the potential
demolition of sexual choice of choice of sexual partner as a part of part of a you dystopian future Friedrich Nietzsche a
Philosopher who described himself as as
Someone who thought with a hammer and Nietzsche is a very very dangerous person and an absolutely Brilliant writer and [Carl] jung who?
Was a student of Nietzsche and who Nietzsche was the philosopher who announced the death of God back in the late?
1800s and jung spent his whole life
Attempting to revivify God that's one way of thinking about it, and so if you or educate yourself
And this is [a] really good place to start if you read these authors then you'll know what else to read if you read these
authors it'll it'll take you a good long time and it will be very very hard on you and and
You won't be the same person when you come out?
And that's very frightening and because being torn down and rebuilt his note is no joke
But it beats the hell out [of] the alternative which is just to stagnate and stay as stagnant infant
Which is which is not something. I recommend there's nothing uglier than a
stagnant 40 year old infant
So that's equivalent. Just so you know - pinocchio back to the pinocchio story
rescuing geppetto from the underworld remember and he was he had kind of turned into a half jackass after being at the
Pleasure Island where he was enticed by the way from a couple of people who that was the fox and the cat who attempted to?
entice himself into believing that he [was] a victim and needed a vacation, so
pinocchio was enticed [onto] pleasure island by two two figures that played on his sense of
Victimization and neuroses and suffering to convince him that he didn't have to he didn't have to take any
[responsibility] for his own existence
And he could just busy himself with impulsive pleasures right that's how he fell into the hands of the totalitarian, so on Pleasure Island
Anyways, Pinocchio after he left?
Pleasure Island had to go into the ocean twice and the second time [he] went into the ocean he was looking for his father well
everyone's father from a mythological perspective is dying in the underworld in the Chaos because
everyone inhabits a culture
that's that's sick and old so to speak and it's sick [and] old because it was made by the dead and
the living have to revivify it continually in order for it to be a
Dynamic Force and the living have to revivify their connection with the culture internally to because you're
Constructions of culture although not only constructions of culture and you have to understand history
Because otherwise you can't understand yourself
You're a historical creature
And so you have to rescue your dead father from the belly of the beast from the dragon
Guests remember the whale in pinocchio is also a fire-breathing dragon
[and] that means you have to face the thing that you most fear and when you do that, you'll rescue your father from the underworld
[these] are very complex ideas and you can read about them in my book maps of meaning if you want it's on the reading list
I put a free copy of it on Jordan B. Peterson [Com] so you can download it
I take apart these sorts of things in detail. So anyways you have to revivify your father before you can become real and
that's part of the problem with the
The [feminists] in feminist and Social Justice warrior insistence on the existence of the patriarchy it's like
Everyone's known since the beginning of time that culture is corrupt and tyrannical
But it's also protective and benevolent even the language used is a product of culture and so you don't overthrow the patriarchy
Yuri vivify your culture and you do that by adopting
Responsibility for your own being and then acting as a moral agent in the culture, that's what you do
To become educated so read these books read these books they'll change your life. I guarantee it. They'll change your life
They'll take you apart. They'll devastate you and then they'll rebuild you into something far greater than you are now [you're] [hurt]
Don't worry
Jenny
You need to get yourself out
Follow the chamber, and you'll find wrong
you
You were brilliant folks. [I] just [wasn't] quick enough
Of course Phoenix tears have healing powers
Thanks
it's alright today and
That's what to aim for
So then and here's something that will help you my colleagues
And I have developed a series of online writing programs called the self authoring suite
And they help people write about their past and organize that and their present
Personality and organize and understand that and then the future and the future authoring program asks you to write about
six different dimensions of your life
so it asks you first of all treat yourself as if you're someone that you want to help and
Lend that someone that you love and take care of and someone that you want to help and then
It asks you well if you could if you [could] organize your life in the best possible Manner and in keeping with those principles
We discussed earlier um
What do you want? What? Do you want for your career like what do you want? What would make your life meaningful?
What do you want for your career? What do you want for your family and from your family?
What do you want for an intimate relationship?
How are you going to handle how are you going to take care of your mental and physical health?
How are you going to handle drug drug and alcohol use it asks you a series [of] fundamental questions like that
To get your mind moving, and then it asks you to write for 15 minutes about what your life could be [like]
fifty three to five years in the future if
it was laid out like you were laying out a life for someone you deeply cared about and
so you're asked to write for 15 minutes about that without worrying too much about structure the structure of the [argument] or
Any grammatical niceties that [that's] put off for later, so that gives you a little heaven dame for right?
It's like well
If I could have this my life would be clearly worthwhile even if I had to put up with a fair bit of suffering along
the way that's what you're trying to construct and you can think about that as a heaven worth moving towards and
then the second part of the program asks you to write about
what your life would be like three to five years down the road if all of your bad habits and nihilistic tendencies and
proclivity towards resentment and lack of Desire to shoulder responsibility
if all your weak points got the upper hand and just ordered you into the ground and
Everyone knows that you know what you'd be like if you just let everything slide and and you know what particular hell
You were ended up heading towards and so the set the second part of the program asks you to write about
What your life would be like three to five years down the road if everything just went to hell around you and so that gives?
you a hell to avoid and heaven to strive for
You need both of those because that's what keeps you properly motivated in life
And then the second half of the program that the next part of the program
helps you turn your vision of the desirable future into an implementable reality and to
Articulate it fully and to articulate the arguments for why you want that and those even help you overcome your own doubts, right?
It's not only to argue against other people
It's to argue against the chattering Demons of Nihilism and hopelessness and ideological
possession that that exists in your mind and in society
Simultaneously you need powerful weapons to fight back against those so here's an offer for you
We've made the future authoring program available free for the next while
I don't know how long a while be but let's assume a week or something like that and
so if you go to
WWL farthing Com Slash future authoring Dot HtML
You can read about the program there and [now] I got to tell you we've used this program on about
5,000 university students so far mostly in Holland, but some in Canada as well, and what we've shown
Is that they the program if you if you complete this program even if you do it badly?
And I would recommend it do it badly man
It doesn't matter you don't have to do it perfectly do it badly
And then maybe do it better as you move forward, but at least do [it] badly it
increases the performance of University students it increases their grades by between 20 and 25 percent and
Decreases their dropout by about the same percent
And so we have doubt on [5,000] [people] one of those papers has been published
and I'll put that in in the description in the [description] of this video and so this program really works if you do it and
And so I would highly recommend that you do it anyways you can read about the program there
click purchase for 1495
Then enter this code change yourself
that'll give you a 1495 discount and that means you can have the program for free and
So here's what Millennials should do if they want to change the world the first thing
they should do is orient themselves to [the] good and that's away from Evil away from malevolence away from the
Manufacture of pointless suffering and pain away from Auschwitz let's say and away from the gulag archipelago
And the terrible soviet camps and the massive murders that occurred in China you want to get it end
you want to get as far away from that as you possibly can whatever direction is away from [that] is a good direction and
and then you also want to
contemplate what the highest possible good could look [like] for you and your family and your society we already discussed that and
Then you need to speak the truth in
Relationship to that and then you need to educate yourself and then you need to
Shoulder your responsibility responsibility is a good thing because it makes you strong to bear up under it makes you strong
You can turn yourself into a you can free yourself
From your strings and turn yourself into a genuine individual and then you can shoulder the world and then you're in a position to make
To make change as a person like that your mere being will change the world in a positive direction
And that's what you should be aiming for so
Read the books that I put up on my site and do the future authoring program, and that will improve your life dramatically
And that's how you can change the world